hi i'm christopher hine and today i'm
going to give you guys a few wakazashi
forms so these are forms that i use for
wakazashi
it's important to understand that
aikido's heritage is tied to traditional
jiu jitsu and traditional weapon based
martial arts in japan and i think when
you see the forms that i'm going to show
you in the way that i'm going to show
them to you it becomes really obvious as
to what all the techniques of aikido are
for and i've made many videos talking
about this you know like i am
an advocate of understanding that
aikido's syllabus was never designed
around unarmed stuff
a bunch of teachers have kind of tried
to
turn it into an unarmed system and
there's been a lot of discussion of
unarmed stuff but unarmed emphasis is
not really what aikido is about and
there's a number of historical reasons
as to why
there's been an over emphasis on unarmed
things but by trying to understand
aikido's technical syllabus as unarmed
you're doing yourself a great disservice
because
a lot of the techniques will seem like
they're not really necessary and so when
you're trying to hash out what aikido is
by not first approaching it as an armed
system it's going to be really really
complicated to understand now after
we've understood it as an armed system
we can start to understand that it
really doesn't actually matter if there
are weapons or not weapons because the
system's built in a way that that really
doesn't matter
but you first have to understand it in
the way i'm going to kind of provide now
so i'm going to go through a few forms
with you with a wakazashi with josh and
i think it'll kind of illuminate a lot
of this stuff for you so i'm going to
get josh over here we're going to go to
work josh
[Music]
[Applause]
all right okay let's think about um some
forms and how they might look like our
taijitsu um and when when you say the
word taijitsu you just mean body skills
usually when we say taijitsu in aikido
class we're talking about the unarmed
stuff and that kind of doesn't exist in
my opinion so let me kind of show you
some of the stuff that i'm sure you're
very familiar with seeing but see it in
a slightly different way okay so if i
had a wakazashi here and it was in my
belt so just a short sword and it's in
my belt and josh reached out to pull it
out right so he's going to grab it he's
going to pull it out he's either going
to grab it katate or he's going to grab
it yakute right now that should be
pretty evident if i had my hand out here
there's katate and there's gyakute so
same thing right okay so let's say he
reached out and grabbed it
okay so here's
all right now what do i want to do well
i clearly don't want this guy holding my
sword so how could i get him off of it
well one way i could do that is step off
the line and shove his elbow off of my
weapon now we see ikkyo omote right
there right so if i said went from
yakitodori here and i came up here's our
ikyo multeform boom there it is right
okay and that of course could go to i
don't want to get into this right now
because it's going to go way off camera
but that could also go all the way
through so let's say i go here and his
arm doesn't come off but i break his
balance a little bit i can break him
down and i can take him all the way to
the ground exactly the same way i would
with a yakutedori ikiyo omotewaza form
okay now let's say this guy grabs it and
i come up here and when i go to shove
his arm he won't let me get under this
elbow right if i push his elbow down and
go towards him we suddenly get gyakute
dorinikyo right so we look here i come
up here i push down on the elbow right
here and i drive the weapon towards him
and we see we're getting enikio right in
there and we're clearing with nikyo so
we immediately get gyakute dorinikyo
form for this
coming over here boom boom boom exactly
the same all right let's say we come up
here and as i go to move it he rigidly
locks his arm in place so i can't move
that guy at all oh i can't even move it
at all if i turn right here and i come
to his elbow and move him off we get
yakuteidori mayutoshi right so he holds
me here and i turn here boom bang and
again that could go all the way down to
the ground or it could be done standing
to finish it up right there all right
let's say he gets this and he pulls the
weapon out right so he really pulls it
in there like that right well what can i
do with that as he pulls it in there i
can come over the top and we get a
kolkanage so now that kokunage is
gyakutedori kokunage right here i came
in here boom yakute ori kokunage right
and of course i could do it with the
over-the-shoulder version or other
versions if i wanted but that basically
idea comes from kokinagi because or
turns too cocky because he's pulling it
in right so as he pulls me in i just
enter right alongside it okay let's say
he pulls it and he clears my weapon
right so he actually gets it away from
me oh that's bad he's immediately going
to put it in the other hand and he's
going to attack me somehow right that's
what he's up to right so now we're
seeing techniques for yokomanuchi right
so let's say he pulled it out and
switched and comes yokomanuchi bang i
enter in there and we have one of our
basic defenses let's say
he was at a further distance so he kind
of hopped back further and so when he
comes in i have to cover more distance
boom there's another one of our entries
for yokomanuchi so now you see how
yokomanuchi directly comes off him
pulling the weapon free and coming to
get me all right what about further from
there so let's say he goes yokomanuchi
and i come here well what's he going to
do he's probably going to try and go
under this and cut my belly boom right
what's the aikido answer for that well
that's this right now that can be turned
of course into
kotagaishi
it could be turned into idi minage where
i go to another weapon right i can do
lots of stuff from that basic position
because
now we're in the yokomanuchi series he
could also draw it back and ski and we
could see the ski series right there's
lots of different techniques we can see
because all of these are built around
weapon conflict originally now when
i'm not going to get into the history of
it because it's going to be a lot of
conjecture for me basically if you
understand these techniques as i'm
showing you right now which is the way
you would see them in traditional
jujitsu all of a sudden iketer
techniques will make a ton of sense to
you and you'll quit trying to work so
much with them on unarmed basis now
that's not to say we can't do unarmed
stuff with it later it's never going to
be mma if you want to get good at
unarmed stuff go study mma it's a way
better way to go if you want to get
better at unarmed grappling go study
brazilian jitsu or greco-roman or
freestyle wrestling something like that
you're gonna get way better doing those
things but in order to understand the
martial art that we know if you start to
look at the forums this way i think
they'll make a lot more sense to you and
i gave some really cursory examples
right here but you can see where they go
already with the forms you have i would
recommend if you're interested in
exploring this stuff get a wakazashi
stick it in your belt and start seeing
how many techniques come out because a
ton will come out for you
i'm christopher hines joshua tihi and
behind that camera is maya solano
mcdaniel
thank you for watching
[Music]
you